[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis u.s.
chess champs calm presents the third
annual winter chess classic hello chess
fans welcome back to st. Louis for round
three of the 2019 winter chess classic
I'm Ben Simon substituting for national
master Caleb Denby and alongside woman
grandmaster sabina for sabina hi dave
free we're still here no catastrophes
yet so there's a lot going on so far
what do you think of the tournament it's
really exciting I'm so happy we see
quite or at least we saw so far a lot of
decisive results but today indeed it
seems like it might be more of a you
know quiet day it's cold outside maybe
everyone is trying to relax a little bit
a peaceful day maybe well let's take a
look at the standings so far after two
rounds in Group A alright well we're
gonna hold off on that in just a moment
do we have the tournament format alright
let's roll that tournament format if
you're just joining us for the first
time we encourage you to check out us
chess champs calm this event it's the
same as it's always been
to ten player round robins the time
control is 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then 30 minutes added on after
40 moves for each player there's a 30
second increment from move number one so
yeah for the kids out there you got to
take notation the entire time and there
are no draw offers before blacks
thirtieth move to encourage fighting
chess and our schedule is as follows
there's no rest days we're going
straight through until Monday November
18th 1 p.m. central round time start
every day our show goes goes on the air
live at 3:30 p.m. Central time and you
can check us out at us chess champs calm
and on YouTube we we are happy to
chat with you in the chant pardon me my
earpiece just fell out there my goodness
but yes like I said us chest champs calm
if you're on Twitter or Facebook use the
hashtag winter chess classic and we are
ready to take a look at our standings in
the a section our masters division the
four players at the top at plus one are
four veterans of the st. Louis chess
club competitions of course Geoffrey
Zhang the four world junior champion
former classic champion here at the club
Gregory Oberon who is a former classic
champion here at the club renowned juma
by of has been here before looking for
his first field victory and of course
the former junior phenom himself Daniel
narrowed its key now 23 years old
they're all tied at the top let's take a
look at our B group standings our
challengers section if you will now we
actually have some players a little out
of order here but I'm gonna give you the
top four Melik catch an Tigran Hartunian
Alexei Sorokin and Federico Perez puns
at much like the a group we have four
players sitting at plus one and so we'll
be taking a look at profiling them here
today the prize fund for this tournament
a very generous offering thirty six
thousand dollars total in field a the
winning champion will get six grand and
in field be the winning champion will
get four grand okay without wasting any
more time
these games are coming to a head let's
take a look at our pairings for group a
now in Group A all of the games are
still underway Samsa beyond vs.
grandmasters set through we have Rina
Juma bio versus Victor Erdos of Hungary
Daniel narrowed its key versus Gregory
Oberon that is a matchup I want to keep
my eye on because we have two of the
leaders playing right there that's true
yeah there are some other very
interesting games going on absolutely
think Alexei Serrano versus var Akopian
and our key matchup today they say it's
pretty darn interesting hapana
kibou Zeon versus Geoffrey Jean Sabina
let's take a glance at our first key
matchup yes because both of the players
had an amazing first round they won some
great games and then yesterday caboose
in actually lost and Geoffrey made a
draw against Seminole seven and today
they are playing each other and this is
the current position that we have I
really I think I like blue white in this
position I'll take white I really think
white is a little bit more active this
Queen in h4 seems a little bit out of
blame what I found interesting about
this game early on is the opening then
as you are keeping up with with the
games of course you're the past two days
I noticed Jeffery was playing the Scotch
with white you know two whites and he
both times he played the scotch and
guess what today it is time to play it
again just this time with the black
pieces so I found that to be a really
interesting thing maybe we can bet on
how many times someone gets to play the
same opening did you ask him when he was
in here he was not here yesterday the
first day yeah the first day and he had
this very interesting preparation that
he had night of six
Knight takes c6 he takes to six and
Bishop d3 and he had a very very
beautiful game the first round and then
he has changed a little bit he's set up
against Sam 7 of course I didn't have
the time to interview him yesterday but
I can see today he's not going for those
lines maybe he doesn't want someone to
play against him that same line you know
when you win you have some good analysis
you don't want to share so much so of
course okay I'm just kidding now but it
is it is nice to to see him play with
both colors and I think as a chess
player if you really want to get better
it's very good to learn your openings
with both colors and feel confident to
play them
so bishops if I first played this is
like a pretty standard theory 93 is
maybe not one of the main lines but what
usually happens here is after ninety
eighty six black usually goes for this
idea
queen of six putting pressure and f2 and
then they get to recapture the night and
I think black usually enjoys this
position are you familiar with these
I'm actually not I think what is White's
best move right here would you say why
it's basically usually its Queen Queen
e2 or Queen d2 I believe one of those
two moves is what white place to protect
the pawn of course it's a little bit
unpleasant because whichever square you
choose for the Queen you're going to
block one of your bishops so afterwards
you have to move the Queen to take those
bishops out but it's they're really long
lines now we get to they need to be
studied I guess if you're playing this
line but 93 is I think still a pretty
pretty good line is just not one of the
top ones caboose can seem to be a very
aggressive player so maybe he you know
he didn't want to allow for the pressure
enough to so in this way for example I
think we have six actually I never asked
myself what would happen if Queen f6 but
it doesn't seem as natural here in this
position so he went for ninety seven
this is usually the the way black
chooses to finish our development Queen
e2 now ideas in this position for white
are to try to make sure we have control
over the e-file so that we avoid any
kind of d5 for black black needs to
finish their development so they might
try to challenge this pawn in the center
so Queen e2 and then with this move also
white basically says I'm going to lock
my bishop in f1 but I'm going to prepare
for some long cut long side castling and
potential attack
and I think that's kind of what it
actually happened in the game if we move
along a little bit castle Bishop III
black is trying to as I mentioned
challenge that pawning the center with a
five Castle and now f4 not sure about
yeah maybe f4 is what do you think about
that for but well
it's adventurous I mean we should white
exchange the bishops retreated back
seems a little bit to pass there's no
future right
yeah the pieces are kind of locked and
if you're going to go for an attack
you really cannot afford to waste too
much time so Bishop takes b6 seems never
seen a bishop move like that that's
crazy
Bishop takes b6 pawn takes B sticks and
now you can be a little bit worried I
agree because you're opening up blacks a
file directly on your king but the way
blacks pawn structure is makes it
difficult for them to actually bring the
pieces to attack so I think the
opposition is not really worried about
this attack the knight in c3 is doing
for the moment a good job protecting and
now he's going to try to actually take
advantage of the fact that this pawn is
in a4 and maybe try to open up the
position on the King side we'll see so
you place f3 first these six a3 this is
an interesting move trying to prevent
any kinds of night before black finishes
their development now we have Queen d2 I
think our position is pretty balanced
for the moment and black decides to make
this positional trade giving up the
bishop for the night here in b3 which in
a way you really don't want to give the
pair of bishops but you are creating
some weaknesses in White's territory and
you might try to take advantage of that
it's not so easy you know
because any kind of ideas would be five
before for example for black if you
manage to prepare it white probably will
consider playing some a4 and then just
keep the position closed if you can
challenge that pawn once again will be
five it would be great but it's always
going to be a fight I think okay so is
this the current position no this is not
the current position I mean this
reminded me of Eric Rosen did a lecture
here once I think he called them pawn
clumps I don't know if that's a formal
term that's a pawn clump wouldn't you
say those three ones on a and B yes it's
not a lost cause until it's just two
isolated doubled pawns right correct and
if they are on an open file then it's
certainly helpful for for the opponent
but here they're not actually both
colors do have those be doubled pawns so
in a way it's going to be very hard to
actually try to find a way to to attack
them but
[ __ ] one bringing the king away from the
C file maybe this file actually you know
it's good to keep the king a little bit
safer I think this is a perfect
placement especially since you mentioned
those pawns B 2 and B 3 kind of keeping
the King safe and now check ok one okay
so white basically just completed their
development put their looks on central
files this is seems very natural c6
alright preparing for some B five white
retreat this is more of a prophylactic
move you don't want B 5 to be played
with tempo so you're just getting ready
for for the moment when b5 will be
played so here you can choose what you
want to do and I really like this move
because otherwise if for example you
would make any kind of random move here
let's just even put h3 the ideas that
you want to avoid in general when there
is somewhat of a hook here so like if
Black gets this pawn to b4 to attack
these two pieces black will force an
opening of the files so b5 would come a
tempo here you need to go back and then
maybe before and here I would force you
to do something about this point in
before you cannot just move the knight I
mean you could but then I would take and
then I open the a file and then if you
take here I have succeeded in doing what
I wanted so this is a very typical idea
and that's why I believe kabuki and just
preventive you're treating with the
bishops of b5 didn't come a tempo and
now 92 making sure that before doesn't
come a temple because you wanted to
answer probably with a 4 I mean in this
specific position maybe he can even
capture that pawn with the Queen but if
black were to prepare it a little bit
more I'm sure a 4 or to be played let's
move on to be faster maybe here to get
to the current position I can see how
excited you are about that we're just
yeah so it's as I said it's not so easy
for black to actually get on the
inside so it seems like Jeffrey is
actually focusing a little bit towards
the kingside Quincy sex night - see -
and now he plays Queen h5 mm-hmm okay I
like this idea queen h5 attracting h3
which means now it's going to be kind of
difficult for Y to push g3 because the
pawn has moved okay but I'm not sure if
I want to leave this Queen over here it
doesn't seem natural the Queen to be on
the other side of the board than the
opponent's kink right right well what if
the Jeep on just doesn't move I mean
then yeah the Queen certainly looks
worse for wear yeah yeah so he brought
it there maybe to attract this move so
that g3 now is not possible
so maybe I'm thinking maybe he could try
to bring the Queen back into the game on
the other side of the board maybe
something like this and I don't know I
would get you on the iPhone maybe you're
like I don't know maybe I'm just
dreaming here but you just feel like
Blackwood wouldn't need the Queen on the
other side but he went for night of 7
this move hmm seems like okay you want
to protect these six but in the same
time that night is so strong there
that's an outpost why would you want to
move it away from there I'm not I'm
personally I'm not happy of course you
know I have this difficult job I think
we both do it to analyze games of very
strong Grandmaster so to say you know
this move is not good or I don't just
walk softly severe water it's dry but I
just personally from the standpoint of
you know positional idea I do not
understand exactly what he was thinking
hopefully we'll find out soon crenate
horn all right so now white make sense
what white is just doubling up on the
default putting pressure on d6 and it's
not so sure how we are going to attack
it another time to actually be able to
capture it
all right so a four oh wow yeah this
move I did not expect I was looking
forward to black playing before but I
guess hmm
84 all right so well yeah yeah that's
certainly an expected movement we'll
have to see the implications of that
coming up but Sabina before we get too
in-depth in this game let's take a look
at our B parents and see what's going on
I know we have at least one result thus
far in the B group Alexei Sorokin has
defeated young Christopher woo
Christopher you rather and in the other
games Sergei Ezra vs. Sergei Ehrenberg
Justin when versus harutunian
emilia Cordova vs. federico perez Panza
and our key matchup I'm sure you'll be
interested today Grandmaster else shot
for India body against one of my good
friends Grandmaster Malik catchy on
let's go take a glance at this game we
may have an interview here coming up as
well you are now L Shawn yesterday had a
had a rough day
he was very bothered by the fact that he
had dropped upon and he just thought he
wasn't on his game but today is a new
day and things may go in his favor let's
take a look sure so yeah yesterday was a
tough day for him I don't know what
happened I maybe I wasn't supportive
enough to help him with the preparation
and then I had to interview his opponent
turned out in a very funny
online video I think what you said was
fair we wish you luck but not too much
yeah you came up with it totally by
yourself it's not like anybody whispered
that here at all is it yeah nobody
didn't know I just came up with that
myself anyway so today he's playing
grandmaster melle kichan who's actually
has been the culture captain of the
women's Olympic team for quite some time
so I know him very well but you know you
have to
you can be friends outside of the
chessboard but I always tell everyone
you know you have to play because this
is also competition so when you get to
play against a friend you still have to
play as if they were not your friends
yeah yeah so I guess really fun how
these relations interact here at this
winter classic that is truants not so
easy here Oh a lot of things have
changed since actually I have lost scene
disposition so I have this rockin game
where black is a pawn up but that
usually does not matter so much in Luke
end games white is way more active seems
like got some pressure on that G pawn
and now 7th ranked in general right and
7th rank of course b7 is very weak and
then White has this protected passed
pawn which is you know very good but now
watches in truck so the we have to kind
of see what is the best placement of the
King because if we go back a few moves
actually so white gave up training the
Knights there are some lights on the
board a little bit earlier so Knight of
three just trading the trading the
Knights and then now it gives up that H
pawn right so that's not that's not
something you you expect to do but if
you get active that's always something
very important so look up 7 hmm ok let's
let's just try to imagine we make some
move here men right so let's say we go
King to d3 for example right ok so now
in this position white still has the
pressure in g7 and of course pressure in
be 7 and black has two moves that I or
maybe three that we should consider one
is just play g5 and try to
just make sure you don't give up that
pawn and don't allow whites both routes
on seventh-ranked some other option
would be to maybe go rook to g5 and
offer a pair of rook trade but I think
if that were to happen that should be
really lost or lack of direction I put
it on the board I believe we can trade
and then I would go for route takes b7
our threatening at this pawn I think the
king should be able to stop the Chi
pawns and this pawn should should be
very strong for white how quite win this
position what do you think well pushing
the e pawn not yet not yet so for
example if you were to play like look at
fate or something I could but I probably
should take here and we have to see for
example g4 what would be the best
decision for white I would definitely
try to do something like this and go
grab the palm back
and then I have this very strong pawn
subpoena I had a question yes of course
in the position but before this I think
it's it might be the current the current
position at the Jeep on mm-hmm
if Al Shean captures the temperatures d7
rook on g2 g7
well this end in an immediate repetition
I mean I would if I get my both rooks on
the suffer example I should say you take
here right I don't think so no this
should be this should not be something
that black would like to get you mean
white would like to get yeah white would
like black would not like yes I think II
seven should be ah maybe not yet I
really want to play seven the problem is
I don't really have a threat when I
check you here you would capture my rook
so that wouldn't really work seems like
Elson actually has made a move son let's
just see yeah so this is the current
position so he actually did play King to
d3 and Grandmaster kutcheon answers g5
Elgin seems very confident I'm looking
at him oh all right this was his idea
okay he seems pretty gone confident he's
uh I guess sometimes I know him you know
I'm just looking at he's a the way he's
a facial yeah well somebody just plays
you can't that's true but without show
sometimes when he's confident I think I
can tell I'm not sure 100%
let's just not try to jinx it or
something right uh you just saw Rena
Juma by up in the foreground we haven't
talked to him yet this tournament but
hopefully at some point definitely well
yeah but this is this is definitely a
fun game to look at I'm kind of worried
though Sabina about the black rook on
the e-file cutting if I was white I
would be very apprehensive about getting
my king trapped away unable to stop that
free Jeep on
moving down the board is that something
I should be concerned about actually
I've just seen a new idea and actually I
like this move that hellström a crook
made rook g2f one here's the idea that
he has so for example you just take the
pawn right because we're worried about
that rook not only is it restricting
White's King but it's also putting
pressure and if black manages to you
know if you just recapture man just to
take and then go back probably you know
you don't really want to get that with
white but I believe this is all Shaw's
idea e7 the idea after this move is rook
FH a candid I do not see a way for black
to stop it you can take here with check
okay that's just one check that you give
and after this I believe blacks should
resign
rook a fate cannot be stopped see after
look I've faith we're just trading
everything and we will be promoted all
right a few more moves are played okay
this seems interesting
alright so black player looked we ate
this is a definitely stopping g7 because
if you're going to play seven of course
one of the rooks was going to capture
your pawn so Allen goes for King to g4
immediately hmm okay so he's trying to
attract probably black to play c5 so
then the thing is when you have two
rooks an endgame with two rooks so both
of both of us with where the two rooks
the it is very important in my opinion
to keep the rooks connected working
together in this case for black they
only have this one rook that's active
right so possibly being able to support
those hng pawns and also restricting
White's King but unfortunately this
routine I ate is not doing so much and
doesn't seem like it's going to be able
to get activated anytime soon so that is
the problem if somehow you could connect
them maybe you'd have some chances of
course you also have upon up so
but in this case if for example black
was took place five we just returned
back to d3 and even if we restricted
these pawns cannot be pushed by
themselves with these rooks you know we
have ideas where you have six some
checks one of those parts is going to
fall so I'm I think probably black in
this position could consider capturing
but the problem after this is that you
still cannot really get your rook active
because as soon as the rook moves away
from the e-file each seven is going to
to be played so it's definitely a very
tough position for for black in my
opinion maybe there's something I don't
see I do not have you know I am not
using a computer any engine currently so
hopefully I'm not missing something
we don't use engines tweeds around yeah
we could but I think it's much nicer if
you know our viewers get the chance to
see our perspectives you know like that
in the raw not you know with an engine
sometimes it's it's very important to
your improvement to try to spend the
time yourself understanding the game if
you put the engine of course you're
going to answer to get the answers much
faster but I think your learning process
is going to be so much slower so I
prefer to work without engines and if
you if you want to see the engine it's
it's not difficult just go to us chess
champs calm and in the chest 24 module
when you click on live watch you will
see they have engines it's great you can
turn them on or off if you would like as
well okay
Sabina I think we should jump over back
to group a for a moment because varoujan
Akopian might be scoring his first point
he's had a rough two days only one of
two players along with set to who has no
points in group a but now against alexei
serrano with the black pieces it's
looking pretty good
whoa so this is the current position
guys it's a for sure man thanks for
pointing this out it's certainly a great
game and
he seems really confident I think
yesterday when we signed off with Caleb
we thought var was going to win his game
he had such a great position but few a
few moments after we signed off I
noticed that
fortunately he had blundered and the
game went you know I mean in the favor
of Daniel Daniel never did ski so yeah
it would be nice to see him you know
come back and he since we see him on the
screen he seems very confident but okay
III guess I say that about everyone they
seem confident I'm just trying not to
reveal their real secrets you know oh
those real secrets tell us I don't know
I don't know just they're all cracking
inside emotionally yeah they just look
like they're confident okay so then the
b3 pawn fell and now this a4 pond looks
like it might be falling and I do not
really see a counter play for white this
Bishop in a1 is completely dead and the
Queen has to stay passive to protect the
weak ink so for sure I mean I'm I'm
expecting a win from far from this
position okay I want to give a shout out
to a few people in the chat Patrick
Dailey it's good to see you back you're
welcome
yes I was the one who unblocked you it
was an accident very sorry but welcome
back yes I've been an employee with the
st. Louis chess club for at least
forever this is a fact and you've been a
viewer for at least forever so that's
cool the e5 rook looks trapped yes in
the yeah that's I would concur Tim our
Patrick as well
Tim priest right on max the chest kid
thanks for joining us so we have the
YouTube chat open if you have any
thoughtful questions or insights send
them our way
and you can also join the conversation
on Twitter hashtag winter chest
classic and there's so much more to come
we've already had one game decided today
in Group B Alexei Sorokin
winning against young Christopher you
and I let's uh let's jump back to group
B and take a look at another game of
course how about let you choose I'm
going to do the best in wing versus
tigran hearts Union let's do that see
hmm
mmm yeah yeah it's a good thing about
starting at the time we do is we really
get to see when these games break down
into the end games for the most part
tigran we talked to yesterday very
soft-spoken individual Justin waiting
two days ago we talked to him I remember
the first time Justin played here at the
st. Louis chess club I believe it was
the winter chess classic 2017 it could
be wrong but he would I call him the kid
with the hat because he was just a tiny
tiny kid walking around with this
baseball cap yeah I remember cuz I did
play him that tournament oh yeah they
lost against him yeah so he's back he's
just a tiny bit taller without the Hat
so it's good to see that he's still
playing the game of kings what's going
on in this game right here oh oh we have
a result it looks like a copia and has
indeed defeated alexei Serena we quote
well dgt is showing it's a draw but you
can see right there that's a win for
black so that will update here shortly
vara Cobian has defeated Alexi Serena so
no doubt we want to get a cobia in here
for this for sure yeah that would be
great and I think he's everyone in San
Louis is rooting for him given that he's
unofficial unofficially anything but
yeah I think he's he's trying very hard
to play good chess and I believe he's
really close to qualifying for the US
Championship next year so he's probably
trying his best to to gain some some
rating in this tournament play some
great chess of course and this is that
crazy that's not a given anymore
you know like he's like oh he's almost
qualified like he was a
he's a mainstay of the US Championship I
think it's unbelievable that he's right
on the edge
you've got Dominguez come in here we had
so a few years back coming here changing
Federation's so it's really really
strong yeah but not just that there are
a lot of youngsters these days who play
really great chests they work very hard
and they have you know they have they
don't need to worry about too much they
just enjoy the game and I think used as
you get older it's not that you don't
play good anymore I think you just have
to continue working even harder because
you know life obligations of course of
course you have kids that you have to
take care of you have other passions too
and then maybe sometimes chest goes on
you know second place or something but
I'm sure he's going to try to do to come
I mean it's a great to come back with
black pieces so I'm sure we'll see other
great games from him but I hope we'll
have you down here in the studio very
soon and this game let's get back to
this game as we are trying to get far to
join us so there's no past pawns and we
have equal material yeah well it's not
really like that it's pretty it's pretty
symmetrical but black is more advanced
we we can see all of these pawns being
pushed a little bit more than wise pawns
and so it's clearly black is more active
just look at their pieces much more
advanced than White's pieces which are
kind of you know of course both rooks
have an open file but this night enough
to is certainly not doing so great
if white would be able to get somehow
this night all the way to d4 I think
they might be doing fine although even
then I'd use it maybe a five before for
black could be
something to be looked out for you know
the idea is as follows if you try to
play for a draw against the Grandmaster
they will find a way to keep pushing you
back pushing you back until eventually
they will succeed so I don't think the
defensive approach works I would say
black is better here
I think Justin just tried to read okay
did he make a move okay night to do it
alright so he's trying to bring the
knight okay so that's the idea
you know I think you always should start
with ideas you should not always just
look for moves you should try to find
ideas first and then look for the moves
to make those ideas happen so here he's
probably trying 93 try to trade the
knight or if not maybe just go for a
much better square for the knight so but
I feel like f4 cookies ah but wait a
second if black does play f4 in this
position then they will give up this
square so they have to think twice if
it's really worth it not sure if you
wonder look there or the night I think
white in this position should be more
worried about their Knight and about the
rook that's my opinion
so f4 I would certainly want to play for
here with black but we'll see if the
ground harutunian is going to go for
that move I would go for it personally
but of course it's not my move so I have
to be careful you can say anything yeah
very interesting so hopefully someone is
going to bring fire to join us oh yes
actually I've just been told that the
one and only vara Cobian is here for an
interview okay so let's pull up the game
and I will see you in just a bit
sounds great let us look
and let's go back through this very
interesting end game of Elgin against
Malik Hutchins so okay no changes have
happened in this game so certainly a
tough position for black and you might
have to wait a little bit longer for
that game the other game that we were
really looking at today and we thought
it's going to be the matchup of the day
was the game between Debussy and her
Highness and Geoffrey Xiang Oh
so this game Oh a lot of things have
happened since we last look at it so it
looks like white got a little bit more
active and then we have some Queen
entering an f2 Bishop h6 alright and we
have var here with us today
well congratulations that's a great game
today
oh yeah how'd you feel about yeah yeah
today was a really good game actually I
was you know I was really upset from
yesterday because you know I played it I
thought I played a pretty good game
yesterday and got a winning position
against Danielle and just not one not
two not three like four or five times
that we win a game yesterday and then I
could draw the game like I don't know
how many times and I just end up over
pressing and losing so it was like the
worst feeling and today I was like okay
I started with two losses I need to just
be solid so I played solid game but then
somehow I got a good position yeah
that's great it's always great
especially if you're playing black
pieces and you have to we were actually
looking at your game yesterday with
Caleb and we really we when we signed
off we thought you're going to win the
game and then I was looking back at the
games I noticed that you had plundered a
few times they play some moves and then
things went south but okay it happens
it's it's nice to know this was a good
this is important win for me because
yeah you say bounce back and now still
with six more games to go so yeah and
did you was this sub prefer
opening preparation no I didn't prepare
that much today I was just like I tried
to play something and he played
everything so he played he fought he
played e-40 played 93 so I want to
prepare against all this I just just
play something that I know so uh I think
the opening was just more or less equal
and c5 the idea is I really need to get
b5 in here yes because if you don't play
b5 there should be seven you always
gonna be worse there so so you really
need to play c5 and the idea is now if B
5 let's say 95 no way you mean instead
of c5 for now instead of he played b3
right so here if you place 95 so the
idea is I have this move Knight d5 which
is very important and then I'm locating
this diagonal and I'm getting my Bishop
absolutely fine so he played b3 I think
this is still theory but I think black
is just absolutely fine
it was extremely solid for both players
he played this move
efore to be honest with you I wasn't so
sure about it for but on the other hand
if he wants to try something what else
he can read it because I'm just gonna
play rook a 58 ok see it and just
extremely solid here so but he for
weakens the position so I don't know
maybe he was trying to play something
like neither first colors or something
but ok logical or crafty eight who have
c8 an important move right here tonight
b8 yeah because I have to bring my
knight to c6 to try to threaten some
night before and I get more ideas I
think this is very important instead of
just sitting there you have to try to
get active and now he played 95 and
again 9 f d7 I want to get to know that
night and bring my other night ok yeah
you don't want to let them trade it just
slowly so for example if you're going to
play here no I don't want to play f6 I
think it's just weekend I was just going
to take
take an icy six and I think I don't have
any problems but I don't think I can be
better either yeah it's it's just that's
why it still has this yeah they managed
to play d4 probably yeah I bet you play
Queen III Queenie - maybe Queen variant
okay in the long run maybe if I trade
dark square Bishop so I can put a rook
on d4 then I have some of the chances
but again I don't have any problem
opening outcome here yeah I mean when
you play black you have to come yeah I
wasn't too ambitious today I just wanted
to make sure I really solidly and now
I'm okay in a tree so the idea is he
stops night before and maybe can be won
he should he should try to just let you
he could but then I play rook cd8 his
idea I think was to play maybe Queen e2
and 23 I didn't see what I can do even
though it looks like when I play 94 I'm
kind of block hitting this but I didn't
see anything better for me so I went for
the Stein okay it's it just should be
equal but I do have a little bit of
space advantage but what happened was
something strange happen very
unexpectedly so first of all I don't
think you should play a force so I think
f4 is already in inaccuracy because he
should just play Bishop h3 and I was
gonna take on c1 Queen Siwan play
something like queen c6
maybe just really gonna be probably
gonna be a draw I didn't see what I can
do here so I I think yeah I mean just
having extra space is not enough yeah
because you know we only have bishops so
yeah if food is actually a little bit
weakening now so and then I think this
is this is a very important moment here
so I think it's cool h6
the whole point now every time he takes
only five I have this Bishop g5 yeah so
that just directly oh yeah yeah that can
destroy the way yes it's nice you have
done rooking c7 not exactly so um so he
took well this was maybe an inaccuracy
maybe should have just played Bishop
four in stage three but again after a
for it you know why it's got some
problems because it
really weakened his position and he has
to be careful now mm-hmm I think it's
probably still manageable but you know I
was gonna play something like Bishop d6
eh you know I can never be worse I have
to keep the pressure and of course like
what what happened take training Sims in
an aural but Ricky no Bishop is better
yeah
the bishop is better don't be cute and
it turned out he lost because of that
Bishop yes just gonna be a draw he
didn't expect it but now you know it
let's say you pick when you see one here
right you don't trade cuz now I have
this h6 give me a lift and also give me
G thoughts good so I think now it's
serious problems here because what about
here taking Bishop g5 Bishop III yeah
this seems like a killer and your queen
in chief are still very strong it's yeah
it's always great guys if you're for
everyone who's watching try to keep your
queen on the opposite color than the
bishop it's much easier said than done
but when you get to Duke and now Bishop
g5 and okay know you're entering in e3 I
am yeah but it's still extremely hard to
win because as you can see there's not
so much material cave areum Porton move
here is the a5 because I don't want to
allow him to play before I want to try
to get as much space as possible and I
want to play the move a4 here fix the
weakness for the bishop and gift so he
played a four and this is very important
before it looks like I'm locking
everything and but it's in a very
difficult position for beau white here
because he basically cannot do anything
he just has to go back and forth now
yeah he seems pretty much kind of in as
well
yeah and this extra pony is usual I
suggest yeah but I have to have to
figure out a way to take it but I cannot
just come in with the Queen and take it
because it's got a queen e3 tactic
that's why you brought the king yeah I
saw that I really like that I was doing
I was trying to do something else like I
played you see this is correct
everything is correct first I was trying
to you just make sure all your pieces
are well pretty place make sure you keep
the tension somewhere and again he
cannot play the move Bishop c1 because I
can take take and Queen b3 it's very
important it has to stay so he played to
make sure nobody four seven okay I I
didn't see anything clear that's okay
I'm gonna go back to this idea and main
differential yeah you see it very
important move by the way keeping an eye
on h3 mm-hmm so and again white barely
can move it's it's so back and forth and
now I brought the King to e6 and of
course he just blundered here he made it
a lot easy queen f1 is just a really bad
move because you just yes he was king
takes e5 actually that I can just take
okay he probably he thought some other
options you know that King b7 yeah but
this is just a great yeah he missed us
if he takes on f7 I go check on d1 and
check on g1 there's a key move and so
but the key is if he had played Queen c2
blunder which loses so sorry Queen d1 e1
f1 f1 this actually I think I'm probably
winning after king takes e5 and then my
plan is actually to go back let's say
you play Queen e2 I go back and I'm
going actually Queen C 6 + f5 why do
oh you go back but the problem is King
gauge to move numbers oh sorry yes so
right here King gauge - I wasn't 100%
sure how I win this because I know I'm
very close but you can't take the point
well actually there's a wait you
couldn't take it
yeah but it doesn't work take take Kim
Ji Won and you don't have Queen B 1
because yes yeah Quincy Quincy 1 really
important so have to take ing 5 and D 5
so you have to put you in somehow
I have to figure out the plan I wasn't
hundred percent sure what is my plan
here I was gonna try Queens if I maybe
go it so after King H to just create
five he goes can't you - so I guess you
can I can go Queenie five now because if
he takes Queen III the king and pawn and
yeah I think it's when a king of you and
I have some moves I have some moves by
also a king c3 so this is winning
luckily so but Queen c2 he is after I
take mini five again if I manage to take
the pawn and come back to the C file
then I will win with the f5 Flom but now
he goes here and I'm not 100% sure now
what's gonna happen here because now
he's starting to activate his queen and
also he's threatening Bishop c1 yes so
tougher well I wonder if you cannot
defend also I don't need to take right
away on would you just move your bishop
first and then try to take it like for
example after King age 225 I like that
move and then King G - can you try to
move the bishop somewhere is there gonna
be kind of - and then so like here for
example
- can we take it well and then he just
waits wait oh I'm sorry this is
interesting Queen d3 maybe I'm still
but okay this is of course it needs to
be calculated
yeah but yeah okay I have some you know
maybe I can do something little bit
different yet I don't know but this is
the way to do it for sure for you yeah
stay put you know I also had another
very hard when you when you try to
defend at some point you'll make a
mistake if you're the one putting the
pressure you're always yes yeah I agree
yeah but luckily I just he made it
easier with the move Queen just wants
the Queen enters just yeah thank you so
much for joining us today is great so
heavy I was wondering when you would get
to win again hopefully I'll be back
again I did the same I never look into
I'm just happy to win after two losses
and just now looking forward to the rest
of the tournament because you know when
you start with two it's like you have
all kinds of things in your head you
know it's like you yeah but tomorrow you
have white pieces and you just have to
yeah I might actually have because it's
not one I have double block I don't know
if it's double black but you know
alright we'll see okay thanks thank you
so much for for joining us is there
anything you want to say to any of the
viewers I know I think this is a really
enjoyable tournament and I want to thank
the Chess Club Center chess club for
hosting this tournament I play a few of
them a year and I think it's a really
good opportunity for the players like my
rating range between you know twenty six
twenty to twenty six seventy it's a
really nice tournament to play and you
know see if you can you know improve you
know get some rating points opportunity
to play people exactly your level so you
know and it conditions are fantastic so
yeah yeah thank you to the club for
organizing it I agree
thanks for having me as well yeah well
thanks for joining us we wish you good
luck in the race runs and we
to see you again here son thanks Abby
alright so as you were getting Ben back
let us see let's go back to our key
matchups of the day I feel like I keep
going on the same games all the time but
let's see if any improvements have
happened in this game
elgyn August manager Chen okay a lot of
things not that many things have changed
but so we had came to d4 and then black
one for g4 in this position very
interesting
so trying to go with the pawn and try to
create some counter play and now because
you push that pawn now we need to to
have some to improve some of our pieces
you have six teams only natural and now
Luke g5 is this move possible then
you're back what do you think about this
position legally is it possible yes oh
it's drawn did they agree on the drawer
is there a mistake and we could get a
shot of them seven why would they agree
on the draw after a seven white should
be winning after look a feint unless I'm
missing something what do you have well
we wouldn't know for sure until we get a
shot of their board if possible but yeah
it's right now dgt is reading draw the
way that the bgt technology works you
know they're all digital boards those
wooden boards they have upstairs that
you see on the cameras and and okay yes
I have it confirmed that this game is a
draw
okay so I'm surprised right but
sometimes it's incorrect they put the
Kings on opposite color squares in the
center to signify a draw black squares
to signify black wins and why for white
of course so it's all mechanical and if
the arbiter puts them on the wrong
squares at first and they have to go and
fix it so how was this side this is what
what has happened so I guess
they agreed on a draw because now white
is just going to repeat the position
over here
I thought white could win but I guess I
was wrong mmm because this tactical idea
with rook g5 and trying to go with that
Jeep on there's no way you can really
stop itself sir look at faith check King
to g7 we cannot just take this rook we
don't have sufficient time to improve in
this position if the rook moves then you
are going to lose the c7 pawn and if we
give one more check here and try to take
it again again it's not going to work
and black will be winning here with this
point going for promotion so I guess
they agreed on a draw after he seven
because white after g3 was going to go
for this repetition over here so so
drawing this group began when also
moments ago in Group A we had a very we
had a draw in a very important game
between two of the four leaders I'm
talking about Grigory Oberon as black
and Daniel Mary disky as white you know
these two had met one time before at a
classical game it was 2014 in Riga and
an open tournament same colors Daniel
had the victory in that game I do
believe there were two junior players
back then but today it's a draw in what
was what could have been a very pivotal
match up in the standings mm-hmm there
anything to talk about here is it just
pretty cut-and-dry I'm not sure if we
actually have the entire game I'm giving
an error for my game do you have the
same position I have the same position
all right yeah all right so I guess
there is wrong here they just reached
move 31 and they decided all right now
it's a time before one of us is going to
try to go for a win of course I'm joking
okay you have to make some jokes
otherwise it might seem like such too
much of a serious we're just dry
dollard's okay one of the games that is
going down right now in Group B Sergei
Azara versus
is Sergei Arenberg a US Championship and
Arenberg the only player in Group B
right now who has not scored anything
thus far and well it's not looking for
him right it's not looking good for him
right now on the clock because he still
has seven moves to make and only about a
minute yeah they're working with a
30-second delay yeah 40 seconds right
yeah pardon me yeah just making sure I
got her eyes we deal with that
Grantchester I got delay on the brain
and that's true it's it's it's a very
tough position for black here because
White has a little bit more space and a
pair of bishops this a six pawn is
pretty weak the night is pretty passive
for the moment so I mean the good thing
about this position I have to say is
that it's closed
so when opposition's not really open
they're not like really force moves
having to be done the fact that you're
in such time trouble it's not as bad
because you can just pretty much shuffle
the pieces around a little bit until you
get to more 40 and then then you get the
chance to think a little bit more less
you will have reached more 40 and
gotten some additional time but still
very tough to make sure you're not
dropping anything there's always a lot
of pressure in these moments I really do
enjoy wise position now I serve one to
Luke a five and now he's trying to just
put additional pressure on that point
probably it's going to be a pretty tough
day for Sergei Lemberg
so Rick a 1 and then b5 could you play
it then could I could try to play b5
maybe I should triple in the file before
I do that because right now you know
you've got a lot of protection on that's
rotini age I could I could try to triple
on the file that would be great and then
just like rogue a two or a three and or
maybe two and then Queen a once
something made that probably I would
love to do and I'm not really seeing a
very easy plan for black so it's
certainly going to be a game to look out
for after the time trouble after day
they will have reached move 40 Sarah may
not be you may not be too familiar with
Sergei Zara here the viewers at home he
is the top seat in this field in my feed
a rating he notably one Marie finished
in first tide on millionaire Monday for
the very first Maresa Ashley's a
millionaire chess back in 2014 and he's
from he's one of the best players in
belarus belarus and number three right
now so we might be seeing a lot more of
him and in this tournament for sure III
wonder if he lives in the US I think
I've seen him play in the United States
a lot I don't know that's a question we
can ask him I will try to ask some
different questions our viewers today I
feel like we love your questions we're
going through the same thing over and
over so I felt like I should make some
small changes
I wonder if I suggest again yes of
course Samsa Beyond versus Grand Master
Sethu in
Group A I'm hearing it's a bombastic
game and we gotta take a look at it that
sounds amazing
all right let's check it out hmm I see
an extra pawn for white right and kind
of a bad night here but there's a bad
night yeah I I do i do prefer why
tonight though because it seems like
it's going to be coming into the game
much easier and now these players are
down to a functional blitz game because
they have eight moves left to the time
control where they each get 30 out
thirty minutes added on two minutes
versus one minute here and they both
have below two minutes okay they aren't
getting the increment but still and it
is hmm that's let's go back a few moves
just to see what has happened so it
seems like Sam actually has had this
extra pawn for quite some time and he
has allowed for some trades Knight to d4
okay he's bringing the King into the
game can seems to have forgotten about
this knight in the margin which I don't
think it's good maybe five attracting
this move a four and now he's going to
prepare to play a five break White's
chain of pawns and that's basically what
has happened that's how black was able
to get the pawn in a five and then get
their Knight trapped over there I enjoy
I suppose the show what do you think Ben
well yeah I mean I would pick white
because the first thing I saw not only
is there an extra pawn on the board but
it's a passed pawn uh-huh and so is it
fair to say that part of black's knight
on the rim right there it's life Duty
now for the rest of the game is to stop
that pawn from going down the board I
mean there's Knights on the rim but
there's not a black pass pawn over on
the edge violator
yes that is true I mean then a pawn is a
passed pawn and that Knight stops it
indeed but also it's a weak pawn so it's
going might be a little bit you know
difficult to actually get to push it
okay but yeah I would take white in this
position it's it could be a very tough
day for the tournament if he ends up
losing this position because he does
come after two losses will sense of Ian
be able to take him down in this game
we'll have to wait and see
Savion just a move here he brought his
knight into the game yeah he didn't like
my knight of five he went through f3
probably he's think he was thinking okay
if I go in at five maybe I I will have
to deal with g6 and my knight will have
to be moved again but if I go to f3 I'm
home I can support that day for pawn
push bring my king closer to the to the
center and then I can think forward on
how I'm going to improve the position
more so you have to take it step by step
to the delay man watching this this
stream and they don't know about the
time increment yes there's 20 seconds
left for Semyon but with 30 second
increment I have to ask you should we
stay on this game until they make time
control or should we go to a game we
haven't seen before certainly stay on
this game yeah little bit
unless you have some very interesting
game that you want to go to it's a game
we haven't looked at yeah we can come
back after the time actually we should
go back to our game of the day for the a
group point yeah okay there's a lot of
things seem to have changed there but we
can certainly check out that show mabye
of Erdos I think that was the game that
you wanted to go guys right
Oh bonus no bonus all right let's look
at all of them yeah
let's go let's go to
let's do that so group a action right
here one of the games we have not seen
yet yes this game we have not seen yet
but I do like white in this position
then white pieces are a little bit more
active
even if black does have a little bit
more space by this pointing in a four
just because you have the pawns pushed a
little bit doesn't necessarily mean it's
always good like here for example
there's no chain of pause for black so
this f5 point could be something you
have to watch for there's some pressure
there we also have currently of course
there's a threat on this nineteen f4 so
we need to move it somewhere I'm
definitely go for ninety six here what
do you think catches my attention
pretty aggressive it's pretty natural
too yeah maybe maybe get the knight to
d4 keeping the default close and then
trying to switch on the C file that
could be something that I can do I mean
it's certainly something to consider and
both of them also are in ton trouble
yeah they're approaching move forty but
they have less than a minute on the
clock and look at Yuma by office time if
that is correct
35 seconds so he probably waited for the
previous move oh he played my move oh I
feel so good when I guess moves you know
I should do this more often
ninety-six rock d7 and our roadie five
as I said you know some pressure on that
a flap on so I guess he didn't he
decided it's not important to rush
moving the knight back to deform just
try to keep some activity and actually
time trouble when both of the players
are really long time I think it's I find
always interesting that they try to make
complicate it moves to to make the
opponent you know be more prone to to
make
stays so look up sticks attack in the
night I'm not sure Jim abaya have just
made a really quick move there he did he
noticed he was down on the clock he went
down to five seconds and this is the
second time he's going to to five
seconds so tough oh look at them look at
this look at how concentrated both of
them are this position they are going to
give their best shot and they still have
three moves to make it until time
control now they're gonna they're gonna
do it and they have to write their moves
we have to point it out when you are
playing a tournament that has increment
you are forced by the rules to write
every single move longer time ago when
there's no increment actually people
were able to just put dots on their
score sheet or just to make lines so
that they actually kind of keep track of
how many moves they had made but these
days where this increment you cannot
treat the system any more
yeah you got to have tried-and-true
notation or else you will be penalized
Sabina we have a result in our key
matchup in Group A a three-fold
repetition on the board kibou Jian and
Zhang have drawn all right no it's
something we would have expected so I
guess today we pick two draws for our
matchups I'm not sure we should do maybe
you should do a better prediction these
games were not right here raucous
laughter in there I don't know what
that's about
I'm just I wonder if we're going to get
any of these players to come down too
well you feel that any of these two
games were interesting enough so that we
asked them to join us okay no no no look
I can't contain my excitement know that
that's up to Danny in the back and Tony
in the other room some players want to
talk let's do it but let's look at a
game that we haven't seen yet and I'm
talking about Amelia Cordova
federico perez Ponza in Group B they
have Peru versus Argentina yep
who another end game and hey look
everybody's in calm here because they've
made time control they had that half
hour each added back on and we're seeing
the video of my responses thinking he
just not seem happy so maybe it's made a
mistake previously doesn't think this
position is winning anymore actually
have not seen the position before but he
does have two points out but the problem
is that one of them is going to be
falling I always made this mistake
it's nope I don't want alright one of
those pawns is going to be lost and hmm
his opponent is walking around maybe
confident that you save the game what do
you think Bend well I'm just I'm curious
what black does right now that's going
to be a problem he has to decide which
of those two pawns to give up it's not
like he can actually save the d6 pawn
unfortunately at that point and fall I
think why should definitely capture that
d6 point first and then see what else is
going to happen
so will you play something as simple as
know for sure not no you really do not
want to go that passive it's black here
I wonder what he has done earlier that
okay so he alright so he probably
miscalculated something in this position
I don't think he was forced to me to
give this check so he won but he wanted
to take White's pair of bishop so he
went 491 check forcing the trade but
maybe this rupee sex is something he
might have missed maybe he thought white
would just captured this pawn in b7 and
then he could do something like no but
still I don't know what what could he
have envisioned in this position
certainly very interesting actually is
there any other okay let's go back to
this game then just in bang against
harutunian because this was a game that
we thought why just trying to play for
the draw I mean we assumed but as I told
you black was kind of more active and I
seen interesting where were we exactly
so I we did see a Ford this was a move
that I had mentioned that I believe
black should do that they have the
ability to get more space on the Kings
side as well so f4 rook to d2 and now
black is switching the file alright rook
to e5 so making sure the white does not
have any kind of activity with the rook
rook trades should not be in white favor
in this position they would love some
traits but not rocket race because this
night is going to die here
so a four so finally just in rank is
trying to make some active moves try to
trace some points in end games when your
passive you usually have to try to find
a way to to get active and the best ways
to try pause because you know you get
get rid of some pieces from the board
and also you create some more file you
open some more files and create some
squares for some of your pieces so this
is a very interesting idea you cannot
take that would be terrible because then
Luke takes and and finally white
detective and you've completely
destroyed that beautiful chain of ponds
so of course black should not touch that
side of the board so hundred onion went
for G for just a moment captured but now
the problem is like he he needs to try
to play some b3 to but it's going to be
very difficult that move does not
currently in work because we capture so
he's retreating to d2 and probably is
going to try to stay here and wait to
see if black has any progress I just
don't see how either side makes progress
here to try to find some way to enter
with the King certainly black now has
some entrance in b3 that's good to keep
in mind for the King later on in case
you're going to get into an endgame
maybe King opponent game or something
you can have that in mind you the King
will just circle around like that and
we'll see if you make it of course white
could stop you with King c2 and no
progress but usually like you try to
find a way to break the Queen side make
sure you push wise King back and then
eventually you get to the other pawns
back on the King side but here we have a
lot of tensions some points that might
get traded so it's not that
it's not that easy to decide how exactly
you want to make the trades I do like an
idea of night III at some point I wonder
if it actually works here
probably not
Sabina I've just been told us we ask and
we shall receive Grandmaster Geoffrey
Zhang will be here in the studio in just
a few minutes all right that would be
great so you need to come up with some
very interesting questions very
interesting questions just just have him
tell his life story they love they love
when you ask I'm not sure I'm not sure
if I'll manage to do that I'll try my
best
I'll try my best let's see by now I feel
that we should have pastime trouble so
if you want to go back to the game
between us Aravind Sergei and Berg so
the time trouble has passed Geoffrey's
ready to come in so get out of here and
take a look at this game in the interim
all right
so as we get Geoffrey all sewed up with
the mic let's take a look at this game
which just finished time trouble and I
move for tea so a lot of things have
changed since we have last seen it
Bishop takes a sick so why finally
managed to take that pawn in a 6 but to
the price of giving up the pawn on e5 so
I'm not sure if that was a good trade or
not we are getting Geoffrey set up here
maybe we can ask his opinion what does
he think about this position as we will
have him
[Music]
nice game inter very balanced game today
I think I was pulled up this disposition
would you mind sharing your thoughts
between mr. games are as Aravind
Sergei Lemberg I was thinking white is
better for a really long time black was
pretty passive but they just got the
chance to take that point in e5
so it's wait edge whites turn they just
made more 40 yeah it looks very
promising for it if he can start pushing
the pawns right away I mean black is
looking for counter play with d3 but
mm-hmm
let's see so I can't I guess I cannot
play d5 right yeah maybe but then you
can take it uh from b5 they promise you
want to take with the bishop or bishop
right justify everything yeah but that's
probably what white wants to do just
start pushing the project they're
connected pass pawns and okay wait let's
see so if you play rook e1 is if you go
Queen d5 I want Bishop f4 just trying to
take anyone wait what if I take oh no my
name is hanging in the end no I can't do
that this might be a tough this might be
a tough position to defend for black
then he made time trouble but mm-hmm
okay let's see if you can move to at
least cover up for Nick
we know six we know maybe if six to come
to and now I want to push be fine
we can take her down Queen yeah there is
no brocade
can you yeah can you go to f5 maybe
instead of s yeah this one I was
thinking but it doesn't seem natural to
put the cream in the bishop on the same
but maybe you're looking for some Queen
c2 in one moment because now maybe b5 is
it possible or not so I wanted to take
on a5 b5 okay follow me
yeah complicated position will have to I
I don't I don't know I maybe maybe I
don't need to play maybe I don't need to
play look cool or maybe I just do this
and then maybe rook see you on would it
be too slow oh definitely possible
because I mean White has a big strategic
advantage but I'm curious why did why
was b5 not working on the previous video
because if you can push
takes Queen takes you take with the
Queen oh and then you go to crew yes and
if you have Bishop C to D Oh
although we good
alright let's let's move move on to to
your game we're talking here a little
bit about your game today how do you
feel about tell tell our viewers how do
you feel about preparing and playing the
same opening with both colors but okay
for me in this particular example I
faced I mean with white I faced Knight
of 6 yeah that's true
and here I play Bishop c5 so it's two
completely different systems I know
so I guess here it wasn't really much
yeah and this is not one it's it's a
good it's not really the main line right
and it's a good I mean one of the played
lines personally I think it's become
more popular maybe it's become more
popular these days so I should refresh
your mind but I mean well the other news
are also played very often Bishop e3
Knights
yeah yeah and how do you feel about this
game was there any moment that you
learned so I don't know so happy I was
thinking around here I don't know if I
have time to go over the entire game I
don't know you know you have another
game to play with the one to keep you
too much but around this position I was
a little bit surprised I really liked
your queen h5 h3 and I wasn't to be
surprised about the retreat knight of
seven yeah well actually to be honest I
wasn't so optimistic about my
even ever since I took on b3 and we got
the structure because I thought it's
difficult for me to form a plan yeah
yeah I was thinking something like this
I don't know if it makes any sense but
maybe try to get your queen on somehow
this other side of the board and tried
to take advantage of I don't know
because again motive to but I don't know
just try to get the Queen on the other
side since the king was there maybe play
some try some c5 before I mean I the
thing is he's just going to double okay
maybe I don't put it is it just on b8
and then try some c5 but it's not so
easy to make it work it's hard to push
any farm perfectly played before and
then b5 that would be great yeah yeah I
think actually the position was
difficult how did you feel what did you
feel that any moment that you might be
maybe a little bit of worse than yeah
yeah yeah yeah like April was strong for
him too great these weak squares I think
I couldn't really afford to yeah yeah so
I tried to lock it up but then it seemed
like he got really active like you're
being able to take that deep d6 pawn
nice yeah I think yeah Queenie for just
to go this takes takes takes here I
think it was critical after okay you
have to guard this back right this is
the critical position and we both didn't
see anything straight forward for white
the main problem is this night on c2 I
think it has no squares to it vhm takes
too long
and
yeah like done structurally it's very
nice for him I mean I've week like
squares everywhere my king is okay
for example he had a chance for rope
takes c6 year 96 Bishop d3 and it's very
close to me I have to play KJ but I
guess it's not more than a draw I mean
he can always play like 26 I have to go
back to a queen g6 back to G if he tries
great then you go back okay yeah yes
Strickland h7 if he wants to play for
whoops I'm sorry I'm sorry
King f7 Bishop c4 I guess I have to go
to f6 mm-hmm but yeah the problem is the
yeah yeah there's not enough to me okay
you can go but now I I probably have a
defense I saw quite a few news 95 is
maybe the most natural stop Queen e6 he
can take on b7 so it gets messy but
after maybe you can take them can take
the Bashara and as you wouldn't have it
keeping it too much
okay 95 I'm not sure about I actually
was thinking Brooke D to put on the open
file and after check to do it up and I
didn't see again without this night it's
hard for me yeah and now you're
controlling d3 square so he can't just
go back to Tunisia
yeah I think I'm okay
even started mm-hmm so yeah that's why
he's this length it was still scary
still yeah it scary but yeah fortunately
I didn't see so sorry instead of rookie
six yeah I wasn't sure I'm pretty sure
he's better but it's really yeah I
thought I thought what was better in
this position but you're right the night
has some trouble and maybe like having
your queen here is actually helpful
because you're always threatening some
checks or queen of trying to decree some
counter play and you're also keeping
your king pretty safe with the Queen
there it's not so easy and I this nights
also like pretty yes support each other
they're not mobile at all yeah so he
probably just tried to get rid of them
but then seems like you're getting some
here yeah this was kind of interesting I
don't have to take well sir let's just
go back the I thought maybe the critical
moves Bishop be fine mmm-hmm you should
be fine now he threatens to take on b5
yeah that's that's this rent he said he
was worried about queens g1 check that
is if can you to Queen G to now the
knight on c2 is hanging you cannot take
okay it's still unclear after 91 Queen
g5 but probably it's okay for me seems
like here you're able to see I keep it
together but the problem for me was
after Queen g1 check he can block with
the night I know again he threatens
rookie what about bringing me a rope
yeah rook da most watchful but now I
think he will
sidestep with the Kings
and Ike my root can never leave back so
this this this game certainly proves
that no matter the result you can still
have a very interesting and complicated
games game and even if you might you
know as a viewer we don't really see
always all this very cool lines yes it's
always nice to have someone come keep
some thoughts on the game show us what
they have thought that's I always find
it very very interesting and
appreciative you know for you coming to
to share your thoughts with us so how do
you feel about about this this result
was are you happy with the with the draw
today overall yeah definitely I didn't
have any chance of winning and I was on
the defensive side for most of the game
so yeah draws considering the game all
right well thank you so much for joining
us and walking us through through your
game some key points and the other game
is well just giving us your thoughts it
means a lot we wish you good luck in the
future rounds and we hope to see you
again here very soon thank you all right
all right so as we get Ben back I think
we're getting ready to close up the show
today but I think maybe we can still
look up at maybe one game trying to
figure out what changes have happened
and this came from group a natural mabye
of against Erdos Victor so they have
finished they have made 40 moves and now
I still really really think that I enjoy
white in this position definitely more
active and we have been back with us
yeah hi that's you again yeah nice and
site for interview from Jeffrey I like
that he was able to he was willing to
look over games on his own
for making him do that I could just make
it work make it work days over okay
that's true but you know he still has a
lot of games to go six more wrong so
they don't want to take too much
advantage of everyone you know right
what during that game we actually had
some results I don't think we had any
new results oh we did not know which was
unusual so we still have two games going
in Group A and three in Group B before
we sign off today though what I'd like
to tell you you can keep on watching at
us chest champs calm but we have the
games are still going there on via the
chest 24 app it's an amazing utility
they've got that engine there like I
said it's all good
so those games will keep on going and
like I said we will go we start the
rounds every day at 1:00 p.m. except the
last round so you want to get back on
tomorrow at 1:00 p.m. on us chess champs
calm start watching the games and 3:30
it's going to be Sabina and Caleb back
in action and they'll be interviewing
the players and analyzing the games we
have a couple of big tournaments coming
up here at the st. Louis chess club to
end out 2019 and one of them is going to
deprive all of us asleep and it's
amazing we have coming up the Tata Steel
India rapid and blitz from November 22nd
to the 26th in US central time this
event will begin at 2:20 in the morning
if you're in India it's going to be
something quite reasonable like 3:00 in
the afternoon so we hope you watch that
at grande chest org and then of course
that has a big bearing on the overall
grand chest or point scheme because the
top four grand chests or point earners
will then meet just a few days later in
London for the grand chess Tour Finals
as a part of the London chess classic so
I think we have the standings let's roll
them for our masters division first
remember we have two games still in
progress we don't have a clear leader
yet Sabina but that's true but that's
okay that's okay and makes it more an
interesting towards the end you know
the towards the last rows are going to
see a lot of fights for the first place
or maybe we'll have a time break and we
will will have a plan we will not have a
tie for first place at the end of this
thing play off that last day we are
gonna have a playoff so it's gonna be a
lot of fun if if they don't settle it in
regulation
and let's dance on over to Group B right
here we have a Lexie Sorokin as of right
now the only decisive winner for today
he's now in clear first but we do see
that perhaps
haru-kun Yin could catch him that game
is still up in the air yeah yeah he's
playing Justin Wang right mm-hmm we
might see a decisive result and he might
catch on to the leaders that's
definitely a game you at home want to be
looking at us chess champs calm but
until tomorrow we will sign off for now
remember Caleb
everybody's favorite host will be back
in this chair tomorrow he was having
some classes today you know improving
his future so that's cool
and we will see you that so this show
was produced as always by the world's
greatest production B team
Tony Chen was the streamer we had Danny
Machuca and Isaac Krantz in the control
room
your woman grandmaster sabina Poyser the
one and only my name is Ben Simon until
tomorrow we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you